we've all seen Terminator 2 the year is
1997 and artificial intelligence is
trying to destroy humanity that
prediction hasn't come true at least not
yet but AI is very much here in the past
decade artificial intelligence has found
real-world applications and everything
from hedge funds to beer brewing and far
from destroying humanity or solving all
of its problems experts question how
much farther AI can go from here
artificial intelligence is software that
solves problems it examines a problem
ventures our guess about what's going on
and learns from what happens when it
ends you can think of it almost like a
giant Excel spreadsheet where you're
running statistics to try and find the
best guess that's Bloomberg Tech's
Ashley Vance is this an apple let's run
all these calculations to see if the
computer thinks it's an apple and has
qualities that remind it of an apple the
companies that are making the most use
out of AI today are companies like
Facebook Google Microsoft and Amazon
it's pretty basic stuff like recognizing
your your face in a photo it's
translating a menu on your Google phone
it's using computer vision in a
self-driving car to see where other cars
are and where obstacles are some of the
first attempts to create artificial
intelligence were in the 1950s with the
arrival of neural networks which is
software that can process data with some
of the pattern recognition techniques
that take place in our brains but it
wasn't until the last decade that AI
really started to take off the internet
finally supplied the kind of data that
these neural nets needed for sustenance
huge volumes of images and text and
that's what allowed all these AI
algorithms to take off today ai systems
can beat humans of things like trading
stocks or playing the board game go
there in driverless cars and can help
identify tumors but the technology
remains limited today's AI still needs
humans to occasionally tell it yes
you're doing the right thing or no that
doesn't look right the end goal of all
of this is to create something that's
called an AGI which is an artificial
general intelligence which would be an
AI that didn't need a human to hold its
hand to tell it what to do
a lot of debate about when or if we will
ever see a GI even the possibility has
made skeptics of people like Elon Musk
and Bill Gates who warned that a I might
end up automating so many tasks the
millions of humans could end up without
jobs or lead to other unforeseen
calamities with artificial intelligence
we are summoning the demon
you